has that been drinking or anything right
no okay drive careful okay thank you
um
foreign
hmm yes
that's hilarious like you as soon as he
knows the cops everyone does the same
thing they're like
it's just like blend into the darkness
[Applause]
it's a normal day
you spend a lot of time doing this since
students are here
that's all that yeah
we're only here for a noise complaint
come to the damn door
doesn't look fresh or anything like
we'll figure out who lives here
eventually yeah
let me go around that I'll be on the
cover yeah
these are all they're all mostly
students so the campus officers can
figure out who lives here and then
honestly it's a lot worse for him
pretty frequently like if they yeah
campus will yeah students get in trouble
they will
um
if they get in trouble they can't this
is actually honestly for like minor
stuff campus will hang up like suspend
them or kick them out all together or
lose all your financial aid like it's
pretty serious so
they've had several kids like get super
hammered and fall off balconies over the
years and stuff and die so they take it
pretty seriously
[Applause]
children
foreign
guys send whoever whoever lives here
down to the door
we're not leaving
and we can also see you
[Applause]
yep
been a property
Master one five seven
do we have any recent involvements at uh
11 22 Queen
everything down now
[Applause]
well no one's here
they go
I have no clue
so you guys just throwing a party in in
their house
they left and went over to some other
party and everyone in the past
I am actually not sure I live across the
state I just came over I haven't been to
drive now female uh
so guarantee they're associated
podcasts
I've been a cop for 22 years
okay
I'm games with me I'd rather deal with
this as a noise
and this is kind of like it's kind of a
fishbowl in here so if they get part of
the echo's crazy
we're not trying to make your life I
understand I just letting you know this
is how it's going to play out I'm not
going anywhere
here
for us that way we can get some sort of
communication between us
no yeah okay thank you yeah thank you
hey guys
there were some coming up behind us and
they I don't know where they went but
they look like they're probably headed
this direction
yes please just go call someone thank
you
all
right
across the street so that means they're
sticking with that guy he pointed right
at it that was not intelligent young man
100
fucking idiots I have to I'll just turn
around a place
take it all to campus back have a nice
day
yep here are the names of the people who
were there
at least
and play stupid games if you want to
there's a party somewhere their music is
real quiet real fast
is the only one that's here yep
they said they're going to another party
I wonder if there's another Greek party
somewhere probably because they would
take an alcohol yeah they're going
somewhere but hey they abandoned it yep
so guess what
we're building alcohol
[Applause]
I like it when they abandon their shit
yep
some more in there
exactly street views
the white claws white claws nice
I hate when I leave my white cloth oh
they're cold too man yeah these are cool
oh God what an open one hello
from college kid yep
okay guys
everybody
um
no one should be a fan of white claws
are true
right now
um
[Music]
load weapon right there Twisted Tea go
back remember that video the dude smokes
that guy
I have no clue
they're gonna be they're gonna be sad
when they come find us yeah
so I tell you guys are signifies
what you graduated I graduated I will
graduated the bachelor's I'm still
getting my masters right now
thank you
yes ma'am okay you enjoy your evening
[Applause]
let's try them out make sure they
actually enjoy the job before you invest
a whole lot more ground yeah so we like
to get them to this point just to get
them hired it's a pretty substantial
like but they do a full background check
tons of interviews we go to all their
previous places of work like we send
people to where they live so just to get
to where you're hired was a big deal and
then it's it's four phases four weeks
each they get progressively more burden
put on them to do the job on their own
basically and so we have like a 50
washout rate yeah so so even if they
were like from out of state you're
trying to send somebody there yeah yep
yep like we send people to Montana and
Illinois and California
heart attack to Sergeant goes talks all
their bosses and yeah pulls all their
records it's crazy because it says a
high liability like if you hire someone
who's got a bad record and you'll find
it it's you're stuck with them so
yeah it's a pretty significant process
no no
my apartment by myself
seriously
there's party over there
it's Halo time
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey ladies how's it going
how are you I'm good
um
[Applause]
yeah they did get on the damn door
hey who's the owner uh or who lives here
um I can go get them real quick okay
please
[Applause]
see these this is what the other group
had to run away oh really
those ones kept walking in the car the
other one
and the property there's a lot of
fucking alcohol
I don't know what sort he lives here
yes
[Applause]
you're not gonna come back
foreign
we're only here for a noise complaint
come to the damn door
foreign
doorbell
whoever lives here needs to come talk to
us or we're going to start doing a lot
more
they just do enjoy it go tell them yeah
just tell them to come to the front door
we'll deal with the noise complaint and
we'll leave yep thank you
I'm in the door guys send whoever worked
whoever lives here down the door
not leaving
you can also see you
yeah
for the most part
they're scared oh my God
that's it
coming down okay
um
so I just looked for everyone that lived
here and they're not here right now no
one's here that no one's here at all no
one's here so everyone hears trespassing
well no one's here has trespassing but
no one no one that lives here right now
so where'd they go
they're just not here I have no clue
where they went no clue so you guys just
throwing a party in in their house at
this time at one point they're not here
right now I just I first they left and
went over to some other party and
everyone is about to at least go over to
another party who does live here what
are their names I am actually not sure I
live across the street I just came over
I haven't drank a job else you know uh I
think it's mainly females I think it's
like four what sorority are they
affiliated with I don't know I don't
yeah I don't know if they're I don't
know
so guarantee they're associated with
sorority
as many of them are living here it's an
off-cances campus story
I've been a cop for 22 years here I'm
not stupid don't play Young games with
me
I'd rather deal with this as a noise
complaint than getting a hold of the
Greek Council and the Greek board and
all of that and the students and playing
all these stupid fucking games do you
also I don't know
because I guarantee you there's a lot of
underage drinking because they left
their alcohol all the time do you want
us to try and get a name or a phone
number and if you can call someone
because you just need to talk to
somebody who lives here because
otherwise I have to be under the
assumption you guys are unlawfully
entered because no one who lives here is
here okay right we'll we'll go we're
going to verify that there was a party
here we'll go get a phone number we'll
be right back sorry we're not trying to
make your life I understand I just
letting you know this is how it's going
to play out I'm not going anywhere until
I talked here's mine just leaving the
door open for us that way we can get
some sort of communication between us
and them we're not going to come in here
right now no yeah okay yeah I know what
I do and hey guys really we're just
coming here for a noise complaints
I apologize for no one coming to the
door
everyone's kind of freaked out because
here you guys are having a good time
right well I just I mean I've been at
another house before and I went out and
talked to the cops but I wasn't no
residents so they just told me to go
back inside basically so no worries so
hey just go ahead and get the contract
thanks man we'll be right back all right
don't tell me this isn't a fucking
off-campus story
have a nice day
who were there
because there's a party somewhere their
music got real quiet real fast real fast
I always complaints done yep
guess what huh
here we go
they abandonment property
you're gonna be so angry
oh they're cold dude yeah these are cold
hello
you do that
from a college kid
all right
yep
um this is one of the owners of us here
right now
hi this is Officer Boston Moscow Police
Department who am I speaking with
Maddie one second let me turn the volume
up on on this uh on this phone here
all right can you hear me Maddie
yes I can hear you okay do you live at
one one two two uh Queen Street
so hey the reason that we're here is
that we received a noise complaint
um of live music partying okay once we
approached the the house uh people
started running away uh deal with too
much alcohol behind we're not even
coming for alcohol we're coming for the
noise complaint and then we sat here for
approximately 10 minutes trying to knock
on the door and no one would come to the
door until these two gentlemen came down
and actually entered the door so
right now
um if I can I would like to collect your
information your name number your date
of birth uh and I'm guessing our and I
want your current address also as well
okay yeah
sounds good I'm so sorry about that it's
okay so let me go ahead and what's your
first name Maddie
and how do you spell that Maddie
my
lucky Isom what's your middle name
Madison
okay what's your last name
m-o-g-e-n
okay what's your name to birth Madison
okay uh in his uh what's your current
address
one one two two King Road
okay
and are you student at uh U of I
okay
all right Madison so here's the deal
okay they've already said that no one
here lives uh like none of the the
occupants that live at this address are
here right now so now you have a house
full of random people
um you need to let them know that the
noise needs to needs to come down okay
we just received a news complaint we
want that music turned down
um and we don't want to come back again
tonight if we have to come back again
tonight then there's even more problems
okay
I'm good I'm just frustrated I'm also
sorry once again
hey I I understand okay uh it's just I
mean if if I were you guys I'd probably
just come home and make sure that
whoever is is partying here is keeping
it down to a minimum okay
um
okay so at this point
um we're gonna leave okay uh and again
if I have to come back later tonight
like I said I I just want to express
that there's going to be some uh some
citations given out okay
yes ma'am okay you enjoy your evening
all right
man thank you thank you hey so uh
yep you already told her about noise yep
all right so what about noise if we have
to come back yeah yeah but I would
probably strongly suggest that anyone
else has left here they don't live here
thank you guys if not I'm gonna come
back
yeah they they were here they went to a
party this could not be the first party
I've ever gone to where the people
but yeah we'll go in though
just let them know I'm not going to
stand out here and wait for him to come
out and give him my keys or anything
like that yeah
that's the first one you're gonna get us
stupid shit right yeah exactly I'm sure
it's not the first time you've heard
somebody say don't do stupid shit in the
topic won't touch you yeah be smart
don't be stupid don't drive it to
yourself right yep so all right thank
you appreciate it oh we're gonna try it
I appreciate you guys going above and
beyond for us and helping us out a
little bit I'm sorry for the issues in
the first place hey it is what it is man
I'm used to it all right let's have a
good one
my hand smells like truly
it's kind of delicious
you chilies are chilies are awesome man
I can drink like 12 of those things not
wake up hungover it's awesome
[Music]
I gotta wait for him to get up here
anyway
City wow this is where we can stop
observe what's going on
see if there's any other activity we
need to be aware of
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
like crazy get on the damn door
oh look at that abandoned property hey
who's the owner uh or who lives here
who's here
um I can go get them real quick okay
please please
truly is this is what the other group
had that ran away
hey those ones kept walking to the car
and the other one around the back corner
so
abandoned property there's a lot of
fucking alcohol in there
a lot
I want to know what sorority lives here
[Music]
[Applause]
that's all the way over there
just everyone fucking ran away
they're not gonna come back
do you think I'm Gonna Leave
we're only here for a noise complaint
come to the damn door
teach you how to knock
the search
doorbell all right
foreign
hey bud we're just here for a noise
complaint can you tell whoever lives
here to come talk to us
we're just here for a noise complaint
whoever lives here needs to come talk to
us or we're going to start doing a lot
more
than just deal with noise yeah just tell
them to come to the front door we'll
deal with the noise complaint and we'll
leave yep thank you
feet
stupid fucking idiot
[Applause]
guys
not leaving
yeah
yeah for the most part
they're scared oh my God
[Applause]
foreign
's coming down now
you've got I think several people coming
down finally
no one's here guys
so everyone hears trespassing
well no one's here that's trespassing
but no one no one that lives here is
here right now so where'd they go
they're just not here I have no clue
where they want no clue so you guys just
throwing a party in in their house that
they were here at one point they're not
here right now I just I just searched
they left and went over to some other
party and everyone is about I just
respond to another party okay who does
live here what are their names I am
actually not sure I live across the
street I just came over I haven't drank
a job male female uh I think it's mainly
females I think that's like four what
sorority are they affiliated with I
don't know I don't yeah you do I don't
know
I don't know so I guarantee you they're
associated with sorority as many of them
are living here it's an off-cancis
campus sorority house I've been a cop
for 22 years here I'm not stupid don't
play gum games with me
I'd rather deal with this as a noise
complaint than getting a hold of the
Greek Council and the Greek board and
all of that and the dean of students and
playing all these stupid fucking games
do you all I want to do is deal with the
noise complaints because I guarantee you
there's a lot of underage drinking
because they left their alcohol behind
do you want us to try and get a name or
a phone number if you could call someone
we just need to talk to somebody who
lives here because otherwise I have to
be under the assumption you guys are
unlawfully entered because you no one
who lives here is here okay right we'll
we'll go so I need to verify that there
was a party here now everyone laughs so
thank you thank you I'm not trying to
make your life I understand I just
letting you know this is how it's going
to play out I'm not going anywhere until
I talk to somebody who actually lives
for us that way we can get some sort of
communication between us
no yeah okay thank you yeah thank you I
do thank you hey guys
yes please just go call someone thank
you
all
right
well they told me they just lived across
the street so that means they're Sigma
he pointed right at it yes he did that
was not smart don't tell me this isn't a
fucking off-campus sorority house yeah
100 100 bunch of fucking idiots if I
have to I'll just start running plates
and attach all of them I was seriously
the same thing kick it all the campus
back have a nice day
they threw a big ass party with underage
Drinkers and they all left and wouldn't
come to the door so they're
uncooperative yep here are the names of
the people who were there
their vehicles are there at least
a bunch of idiots there's a party
somewhere
real fast real fast is the only one that
I hear yep
they said they're going to another party
owners there's another Greek party
somewhere probably because they were
they were taking alcohol somewhere they
were going somewhere but hey they
abandoned it yep so guess what
start dumping alcohol
they abandoned property
I like it when they abandon their shit
wait claws
they're gonna be so angry at me
oh dude man yeah these are cold
oh my God but that one was already
opened hello
all right Josh Jordan you talk to them
yep Maddie
okay
just remind people that we can be fairly
reasonable but when people want to be
dumb we have a tendency to be assholes
this is abandoned property so we're
dumping it and gonna walk away they're
gonna leave their alcohol when they see
us and run away they abandon it and now
we're here I don't know how the fuck
people drink this anyway
never had one never will no one should
be a fan of white Club coming for
alcohol because you would just drink a
choice thing mine I don't drink
good on you I wish I didn't if I did
when I was in college I drank like a son
of a bitch don't get me wrong
I remember what it's like being a
college kid
I'm getting here
also as well okay yeah I'm gonna take
that appeared this I'm going to assume
is not okay
but it could be though maybe maybe yes
looks like vodka yeah I'm thinking so
all right
I'm sure I don't know you can leave it
there I'm sure whoever stashed it we'll
come grab it now they're going to come
back yeah
so I tell you guys are Sigma caves uh
honest
why you graduated you graduated there
you go I won't graduated the bachelor's
I'm still getting my master's right now
so what you getting messages
oh cool okay I actually got a kid of
mine who's starting that program here
really what's his name Eric it's the
first here
you won't know him yet did he go through
Russia at all no okay no don't take this
the wrong way I told him if he joined a
fraternity I was going to disown him
yeah I know what you're going to say and
I I don't blame you I see both sides of
it I did it because I know his
personality and after a while he would
just be pissed off with everybody yeah
I was in a different kind of fraternity
I was not in a scholarly
I played football uh okay Idaho States
yeah I played there for two years Rocky
Mountain College for two years and then
I went to that was a fullback man okay
all right until my last year my last
year I was in those guard
okay
so
pretty fun thank you hey so uh finish
dumping stuff also you already told her
about noise yep well I'm not gonna work
you guys from noise because you don't
live here yeah yeah but I would probably
strongly suggest that anyone else has
left here if they don't live here y'all
should probably leave together I
wouldn't know cool thank you guys
because if not I'm gonna come back yeah
I don't think you want to you don't I'm
not saying you are yeah they they were
this they went to a party this would not
be the first party I've ever gone to or
the people who live here leave and just
let people stay why they do that I don't
know that to me that would be stupid I'm
not gonna let people stay where I live
and it's responsible oh I know trust me
like I said I've done this for 22 years
man I get it yes yeah
but yeah we'll go let him know and yeah
make sure and just let them know I'm not
going to stand out here and wait for him
to come out and try and give him mips or
anything like that but in the same term
tell them not to leave with alcohol yeah
okay because that's the first way you're
going to get us to contact you yeah
don't do stupid shit right yeah exactly
I'm sure it's not the first time you've
heard somebody say don't do stupid shit
and the cops won't touch you yep be
smart don't be stupid don't draw
attention to yourself
right yep cool all right well thank you
appreciate it oh we're gonna try it I
appreciate you guys going above and
beyond for us and helping us out a
little bit I'm sorry for the issues in
the first place so hey it is what it is
man I'm used to it all right you guys
have a good one
I'm already done
that was successful
[Applause]
I don't know that grapefruit one
actually smelled pretty damn good
I don't think I could have drank it but
it smelled good
all right
thanks guys